[Musik]
ja ich habe viele modemacher großes
vertrauen da im raum verspüre große
stille
es ist zweiter die medien ich aus war
die beschäftigten trennen die vorträge
markus ritter ist nationalrat der cvp
nicht verwunderlich ist ein heiliger wie
niklaus von flüe sein vorbild aber da
passt noch mehr zusammen
da ist natürlich buch sie wie haube und
zwar immer eine ganz enge bezüge spiele
selber sich ev in der landwirtschaft
selbst während jahrzehnte engagiert sei
da und öffentlichem tätig ist und sich
nachher ganz kurz wenn der täter hatte
wenig wäre eine wo sich sehr viel in
afrika hat für da aber moment werde ich
kein anderer abbruch als auch im raum
dortmund zum mega 1 niederlage
markus ritter ist der oberste schweizer
bauern und gleichzeitig ihr eifrigste
missionar gemeinsam mit sohn adrian
holte sich den segen beim herrgott ein
wichtiger tag steht bevor abstimmung zur
ernährungssicherheit für ritter eine
herzensangelegenheit sein junior wird in
dafür quer durchs land chauffieren
warum sich da einer der bauernschaft
bedingungslos verschrieben hat davon
handelt dieser film
[Musik]
monatelang hat er auf diesen tag
hingearbeitet werden soll es ein großer
erfolg
ein halbes jahr zuvor
markus ritter heim auf seinem hof in st
galler rheintal gemeinsam mit seiner
frau bewirtschaftete er denn der berg
zone einen 28 hektar großen betrieb
rindvieh ist das kerngeschäft des
biobauern große namen wie zahle ich
weder die rente ist eigentlich schon der
körper vitali dazu stellen wie er da
diana hat jedes navi ist sehr schwierig
da haben wir haben ja nicht so viel also
wenn der bub natürlich bei ihrer wahl im
parlament kennt sollte ja kein mensch
solche sprüche sind typisch für ritter
zu sprudeln aus ihm heraus auf diesem
hof ist er aufgewachsen
seit generationen ist seine familie da
aktien erhöht
noch ist das geld
die kämpfernatur habe vom verstorbenen
vater erzählt mir ritter von der mutter
was ganz anderes
ja denn eine friedliche atmosphäre
vieles also alles sehen vieles übersehen
übersee java und net ja alles hören
viele super hören als höhere drücke bis
denn nun sind sie also ich habe so viel
geld
auf riethers hof waren schon viele zu
besuch
freund und feind und haufenweise
journalisten durchaus kalkül manchen
bauern kritiker ist schon verstummte
rubenow ball der bescheidenheit des
chefs gerne packt er an und liefert
geschichten dazu
so erfahre ich warum er die 220
hochstammbäume höchstpersönlich
zurechtstutzt marseille bis verstoß
gegen verschiedene varianten wie im
leben immer da und würfeln geben dürfe
we love macher von bode hat er wohl
machen so charta für und da muss ich
selber so sie schaden auch hatte falsch
ist aber korrekt
ich selber vater abgaben
selbst für den seiltanz zur
ernährungssicherheit findet er im geäst
einen symbolträchtigen vergleich jede
situation ich immer wieder abschätzen
wie viel risiko nimmt weder welt ist er
richtig geben armee und mich vor gebe es
aber wichtig dass man flexibel ich weiß
jetzt bessere initiative fordere ich sie
wenn das geschafft hat von der
initiative musste ich die sammelergebnis
cannes die zuschauer begeistert sie sind
rechtlich ein gegenvorschlag nicht aus
die nicht du aber zb inhalt zum die
eigenen leute wieder auf berlin jetzt
bringen da ich denn so fordere ich sie
am bau dir beruf zeitlich flexibel zu
events situation wieder vereinbart die
zukunft gehöre den wendigen
organisationen oder akku dritter
natürlich meint er damit auch seinen
eigenen verband
[Musik]
seit sechs jahren ist markus ritschel
für die bahnen bundesbahn sein einziges
lobby mandats wie er betont es ist
frühjahr session den gegenvorschlag zur
bauen initiative kommt zur abstimmung
überraschungen wird es keine geben
der rest ist gekappt die bauernvertreter
werden den gegenvorschlag unterstützen
manch einer zähneknirschend mit vielen
gesprächen hat dritte die basis auf kurs
gebracht mit dem köder erfolg gebe es
nur mit dieser grün angehauchten
vorlagen kommen zur schlussabstimmung
entwurf zwei bundesbeschluss über die
ernährungssicherheit direktor
gegenentwurf zur volksinitiative für
ernährungssicherheit und ich schon
lamina wittig schlimmsten und kostet ab
sie können stimmen
[Musik]
sie haben den bundesbeschluss in der
schlussabstimmung mit 175 zu fünf bei 10
enthaltungen angenommen
trotz des durchschlagenden erfolgs gibt
es heftige kritik gegen das vorgehen der
bauern sollen wir für fast genau
beschrieb die überall drehstart wo
gesetzgeberische wirken auch die alle wo
die fürstin sagen oder andere zum status
quo oder dann ist das eine für alle da
sollte man nicht machen
wenn du machst das gut an
also pure natürlichen enorm groß die
lobby und das hat der große wille die
gesichtswahrung service machen figuren
das kann man so verstehen will ich auch
andere organisationen rufen und daher
tabu das hat druck gut rein anzahl mäßig
sind die bauern im parlament längst
nicht die größte lobby die spitze des
verbandes ist aber bewusst auf die
bürgerlichen parteien verteilt
und die klassen die cvp unterstützt der
verband bedingungslos und das geht mir
praktisch schon alles was diamanten
mehrheit
eigentlich sollte die nächste fuhre
verbannt worden dass bei anderen
politisch jedes ein monothematisches
kollegen halten
diabetiker die machen
kuhhandel also würden sie hier dem
parlament betreiben die bauern politiker
ein happiger vorwurf an die adresse von
ritter oder hansjörg walter nein das
wäre falsch wenn wir so ihr argument die
hre ohne tore
da wäre ja nötigungen beruhigt und dass
es keine parlamentarierin oder ein
parlamentarier sondern nur als vorbild
politisch unglaubwürdig sie
glaubwürdiger wir haben von der
politischen zudem vor durch das neue
stück handle
darin unterstützen darüber nicht korrekt
wenn man sollte es wohl machen aber um
40 verhandlungen malura dass man
mehrheit der über und marcelino
fernandez jedem sperrfrist die schau
macht dass man miteinander nach lösungen
sucht der köder oder zurück brauchen wir
andere lobbyisten wird politiker naja so
physischen heimat
wir sind selber daumenbruch country
logisch der böse starten soll ist
unterstützt mit führung sprach selber
für heute ist die sache geritzt die
initiative ernährungssicherheit wird
zurückgezogen der gegenvorschlag soll
nun unter deutungshoheit des
bauernverbandes im volk gestreut werden
der bauernpräsident
wieder daheim in altstätten ja da ist
zentraler raum schafe im büro da ich
fotos tonne denken und lenken
für mich ganz wichtig ist ein ort wo mir
sehr gut konzentrieren
für mich oder blick wichtig da sie da
heißt vögel beim augenblick als für mein
ganzer wichtige richtigen ort zu
schaffen wie die abstimmung zur
ernährungssicherheit geführt wird ist
längst zu papier gebracht weil keine
nennenswerte opposition vorhanden ist
soll es eine pr kampagne für die bauern
werden dass er buchstäblich rund um die
uhr für den job zur verfügung steht ist
nun möglich dank heidi sie hält ihm den
rücken frei
heidi hetzer dirigiert die angestellten
und macht die arbeit von bauer und
bäuerin
ich denke man muss dabei die
mitgenommenen bespricht er vorher auf
das wäre das ende von quelle piske
lehrer besprechen 15 fahren
ganz ehrlich und jetzt wünschen es würde
einfach nach der abstimmung
[Musik]
heidi und markus haben sich sozusagen
über den mist stock kennengelernt
seit über 20 jahren sind sie verheiratet
sehr hübsch
es ist die hölle gerade zimmer hübschen
erklärt und auch vom charakter her und
um vor der lebensstil leben sie ständig
natürlich sehr gut zu mir passt es
wichtig uns langsam heben wir haben
robert enke immer wieder mit den
generationen denkt na ja fast eine
stunde früher
drei kinder haben die beiden heidi
scheint in diesem haus für alles und
mehr zuständig zu sein
sämtliche rollen füllt sie perfekt aus
und muss am sonntag sogar leisten
dementsprechend unterricht und
funktionäre kurze sitzung des
bauernverbandes in bern monatliches
treffen die vereinigte agrarlobby
versammelt sich im vorstand vertreten
die grossen kantone und die wichtigsten
fachverbände die milchproduzenten die
schweinezüchter oder die fenaco man ist
sich der schlagkraft bewusst und legt
wert auf die scheidungs bild wenn
gefilmt wird
urs schneider ist quasi die rechte hand
von markus ritter in der deutschschweiz
sind sie die beiden köpfe des
bauernverbandes oder die sez im fußball
schalke ausdrückt
präsident sitzen unsere zähne 60 euro
mittelstürmer herzig kantons thurgau und
dort soll bieten symbol ist da ist
ungefähr durch teile schneidet paukt die
kampagne ernährungssicherheit noch
einmal durch guter gesetzte
vorstandsmitglieder jetzt auch dieses
erscheinungsbild bis auf gemeinde stufe
ist alles minuziös organisiert ist ein
entscheid gefällt müssen alle loyal sein
militärische führungsgrundsätze zwischen
zwei traktanden ruft hey die von zu
hause immer volle kraft voraus ist die
tester diese
[Musik]
ein pakt mit dem tierschutz fürs wurde
weiter quer wird unterzeichnet
[Musik]
weitere entwicklung eines direktzahlung
programms schwierig nützlich ist kein
geld aber sind auch extrem viel los
immer über den mittag und dann den nutz
bach zieht zum hauptfilm sitze gamache
bärtschi laura hand besser esser nicht
so wichtig
[Musik]
lukas ja da wo auch schon wie sie uns
ein prall gefüllter tag neigt sich dem
ende zu
[Musik]
im zug dann die bestätigung der
entscheid fürs mähen am nachmittag war
richtig zweieinhalb stunden bleiben nun
bis altstätten um mails abzuarbeiten und
dokumente durch zuordnen
[Musik]
50 jahre alt wurde er kürzlich die
weichen auf dem betrieb sind gestellt
die beiden söhne lernen landwirt geplant
ist dass sie dereinst den betrieb
übernehmen gar nicht bestehen schon es
wäre aber verfehlt bei markus ritter von
zäsur im leben zu sprechen
das gegenteil ist der fall er hat gar
die eigenwillige theorie wenn man das
tempo hochhalten brennemann nicht aus
der hand riss für hebt die die
machtübernahme recht oder das bruch der
standard dann kann ihn immer wieder mit
landwirtschaft zurück zu ihrer und
landwirtschaftlicher da war mir die
größte befriedigung bringt außer betrieb
die natur werde beim hörder hand und da
kann man mit kritik natürlich gut
angeordnete manchmal verliert hat angst
dass man irgendwann ein 33 jähriger
persönliche finanzielle bedrängnis
braucht wer wie das beste hält man immer
eine reserve 30 schönen tag jedem extrem
kraft
spuren hinterlassen möchte er hienieden
oder die er es nennt die geschichte der
schweizer landwirtschaft mitstreiten
ehemaligen hof stand sieht sie auch
bekommt daher erhöht jetzt wieder drüber
52 familien da muss ich darauf verlangt
dass mir der job mache der schweiz und
ich habe nicht selber nun dahinter der
grundlage aller voraussetzungen denke es
geht laut dem wall besteuerung
geschlafen und war dann im jura irgendwo
die verlässt man doch das vertrauen
rechtfertigen da ich dachte es
erforderlich und wenn sie da nicht
machen wenn sie den anspruch nicht an
wenn sie nicht anrichten kann sonntag
vor einer woche
es ist erntedank zur abstimmung kommt
die von den bauern angestoßene vorlage
ernährungssicherheit
besser könnte es nicht passen es bleibt
das geheimnis wer das gewechselt hat sf
1 und 4 news die abstimmung sendung on
air und online es 11.10 / abstimmen
folge verwandelt der rede marathon
beginnt kurze diskussion darüber mit
markus ritter bauernverbandspräsident
und rudi moser fdp ständerat bei und ein
mann er trotz der die klingen mit seinem
kontrahenten kritik scheint an ritter
abzukühlen
das zitat der mutter fällt mir ein
vieles überhören mitfahrer namens
abstimmungs fest hätte eigentlich auch
heidi sollen
doch daheim hat eine kuh gekalbt
[Musik]
an diesem besonderen tag wird der
bauernpräsident auch öko liberale und
natur verbände baden das kriegsbeil ist
für den moment begreifen
[Musik]
schon als bub in der schule habe er
immer der beste sein sollen hat mir
markus ritter einmal gesagt angesichts
dessen muss dieser tag wohl ein sehr
glücklicher für ihn gewesen sein
für sich selber sondern auf den bahamas
gemacht
petersburg ganz alleine weil er abends
noch ein bisschen feiern und analysieren
und wohl planen was für geschäfte sich
nun daraus machen lassen
[Musik]
reporter wurde ihnen präsentiert von
world webforum die business konferenz
für digitale revolution